so Margo is it true that you had a
sleepover like for the cast before the
movie we had a Bobby sleepover it was it
was as fun as you as as it sounds yeah
it was you're welcome yeah it was
Greta's idea I can't take credit we all
went to like claridges which is a really
gorgeous hotel in in London we all like
shared beds and like our pajamas and
ordered room service and played games
and found out that America is like
exceptionally competitive
I am extremely competitive and nobody
told me that it was a sexy Barbie
sleepover so everybody was in like
really pretty silky nightgowns and I was
in like the most Grandma floral twin set
you could imagine yeah how
simultaneously looked like an old lady
but a five-year-old at the same time it
was the cutest and she's so teeny while
she's yelling at you while she's
screaming at you but it was very it was
it was so Charming I mean she was like
this cutest little thing you'd put like
a toddler in to go to bed and then she
was like rousing at us for not knowing
the rules yeah
if you're not gonna compete why play
[Music]
[Applause]